[Music]
extreme mountain biker Harold Phillip in
the northern Italian Alps here we're
even experienced mountain climbers are
breathless he takes his bike to its and
his limits
please equals of unifo there is
definitely a risk risk has a certain
appeal when you go to the absolutely
outermost edge of your comfort zone and
don't know if you're up to the challenge
that's where it gets really interesting
[Music]
during the ride Harold experiences and
endorphin rush enthusiasts call this
mental state flow
when you're really in this flow at these
moments you aren't thinking at all
you're just totally immersed in cycling
for me the next two and a half seconds
stretch as a whole universe I become one
with my bike nearly a total rush on the
way back down to the valley can be Fedak
- hey let's do yours [ __ ] filing real
Oh is dangerous it's always pulling you
to go one step further where I found my
flow yesterday I don't find it today
it's when you're not in the flow but can
think about what's around you that you
can find a direction to develop it
nothing will be more dangerous and close
to the abyss as the via ferrata
definitely a mind-blowing experience
[Music]
even mountain climbing with a bike over
your shoulder is a mind-blowing
experience the film called via ferrata
documents harold phillips tore over
three climbs in the brentd Dolomites in
italy
[Music]
without a safety cable the edge always
in sight doesn't it - of whatever this
is a tour where you can't afford to make
any mistake that's the stupid part but
it's also what's so exhilarating that
all of what happens depends 100% on me
why do I ride a path that's so dangerous
there really isn't a sensible answer to
that but something about it drew me to
it and when I completed this tour I had
the feeling I'd outdone myself
hongbin does he super Moschino give
accent bindis a moment together with the
sports scientists the extreme cyclist
has written a book about his experiences
and the flow
[Music]
how old Phillip plans his bicycle
adventures painstakingly at home in the
Austrian city of Innsbruck he analyzes
even the smallest rock faces on the
mountain before every tour even this
ones exciting because the landscape is
so majestic it goes over this Ridge and
then down here and it must be pretty
fantastic when you get such a great view
into the valley when you can plickers
Manhattan's tire
[Music]
how old Phillip wants to share his
experiences with other people that's why
he writes books shoots film and gives
lectures all over Europe
I want to convey the feeling I have when
I'm up on the mountain it's not being a
hero
I don't either peak and theatrically say
tada I'm going to conquer it it just
feels great to be outdoors in nature
I wouldn't say what I do make sense but
it makes me happy does me save igloo
Kuzma that's why he'll continue spending
hours carrying his bike on his back up a
mountain
[Music]
for a descent that lasts only a few
minutes but what minutes they are
[Music]
you